Das ist ein wirklich kurioses Stellenangebot:
Das “Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt”
(DLR) sucht Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer,
die insgesamt 60 Tage einfach nur herumliegen
müssen.
In dieser Bettruhe-Studie werden die Auswirkungen
der Schwerelosigkeit auf den menschlichen
Körper untersucht.
Hier passiert wirklich alles im Liegen: das
Waschen, Essen und selbst der Toiletten-”Gang”!
Dafür gibt es dann rund 16.000 Euro und man
ist wichtiger Teil der Weltraumforschung!
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Das ganze Experiment, das das “Deutsche
Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt” (DLR)
im Auftrag der NASA und ESA ausführt, dauert
89 Tage.
Ganze 60 Tage davon werden die Teilnehmerinnen
und Teilnehmer liegend verbringen.
Ohne Kopfkissen und die Beine leicht erhöht.
Auch der Kopf muss runter: Die Einstellung
des Bettes sorgt für eine Liege-Position
in einer 6°-Kopftieflage.
Das alles hat natürlich auch einen Grund.
Schließlich sollen die Bedingungen des Weltalls
simuliert werden und vor allem der Abbau der
Muskeln gefördert werden.
Denn genau das passiert bei einer Reise in
den Weltraum: Die Schwerelosigkeit führt
zu einer sinkenden Knochendichte und dem Abbau
von Muskeln.
Aber es gibt weitere physiologische Veränderungen.
Zum Beispiel verschieben sich die Körperflüssigkeiten
in Richtung Kopf, was Folgen für das Herz-Kreislaufsystem
mit sich bringt.
Höhlräume im Gehirn füllen sich mit Flüssigkeit
und die Augen werden schlechter.
Wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Mit Hilfe der Studie sollen Gegenmaßnahmen
entwickelt werden, die diese negativen Effekte
der Schwerelosigkeit für Frauen und Männer
im All mindern.
So werden die insgesamt 24 Freiwilligen in
zwei Gruppen eingeteilt.
Nach einer 15-tägigen Eingewöhnungsphase,
werden die Einen 60 Tage lang einfach nur
durchgängig in ihren Betten liegen.
Die Anderen werden in regelmäßigen Abständen
in eine spezielle Zentrifuge - die sogenannte
Kurzarm-Humanzentrifuge - gebracht.
In liegender Position natürlich.
Solch eine Zentrifuge könnte nämlich bei
Ausflügen ins Weltall künstliche Schwerkraft
erzeugen und sich so positiv auf den menschlichen
Körper auswirken.
Letztendlich soll die Studie in Köln zeigen,
ob solche kurzen Momente der Gravitation einen
gesundheitlichen Vorteil mit sich bringen.
Nach den 60 Tagen im Bett ist dann eine zweiwöchige
REHA mit Physiotherapie vorgesehen.
Sie ähnelt dem Prozess, den Astronautinnen
und Astronauten nach ihren Missionen durchlaufen,
um wieder zu Kraft zu kommen und Muskeln aufzubauen.
Alle Phasen und Experimente werden natürlich
medizinisch überwacht.
Doch auch, wenn das Ganze erst einmal nach
einem äußerst chilligen Jobangebot klingt,
ist das Experiment doch nicht Ohne.
Die 12 Teilnehmerinnen und 12 Teilnehmer müssen
zum einen an Tests zu Gleichgewicht, Muskelkraft
und regelmäßigen Blutabnahmen, teilnehmen.
Zudem ist die 60-tägige Bettruhe sicherlich
nur am Anfang entspannend.
Denn schließlich ist es keine Option, auch
nur kurz aufzustehen.
Alles passiert im Liegen: Duschen, Essen,
die Freizeitgestaltung und auch der Toilettengang.
Hier wünscht man sich nach einiger Zeit bestimmt,
dass endlich der Wecker klingelt und man aus
dem Bett aufstehen darf!
Der einzige “Luxus”: Sowohl Rückenlage,
auch auch Bauch- und Seitlage sind erlaubt
:) In seinem Einzelzimmer wird man mit einer
Kamera überwacht, um auch wirklich eine korrekte
Körperhaltung zu gewährleisten.
Das kann bestimmt schnell langweilig werden,
denn auch Besuch ist in diesen zwei Monaten
nicht erlaubt.
Und so rät das DLR dazu, sich in dieser Zeit
einer bestimmten Aktivität zu widmen, wie
etwa dem Lernen einer neuen Sprache.
Als Aufwandsentschädigung für die vollständige
Teilnahme, die auch noch eine vier Vorsorge-
und vier Nachuntersuchungen beinhaltet, gibt
es dann 16.500 Euro.
Bewerben können sich gesunde Frauen und Männer
zwischen 24 und 55 Jahre alt sind, die Deutsch
sprechen und nicht rauchen.
Cool ist es ja wirklich, dass man als Freiwilliger
wirklich wesentlich zur Raumfahrtforschung
beiträgt!
Nicht umsonst werden die Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer von den Forschungsteams des DLR
auch als “terrestrische Astronauten” bezeichnet.
Wer das übersteht, hat vielleicht das Zeug
zum Astronauten!
in diesem Video: erfahrt ihr im Astronatuentraining
von Alexander Gerst persönlich, was man als
echter Astronaut an Kräften aushalten muss!
Anklicken, anschauen und abonnieren, würde
ich mal sagen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!